a lot of talk first about the look of
the movie because it looks different to
me than most animated features that I
see it has more of a cartoony 2d
traditional animation feel even though
it's CG let's let's talk about that and
adapt using that the techniques you did
to adapt what people knew of Captain
Underpants and to makes it into a film
fairly sure obviously we had the benefit
of 12 books that they've toki has
created over the past 20 years and dave
is not just the writer he's an
illustrator and his illustrations are
really quite cartoony to begin with
they've got a dave was very influenced
by Charles Schulz and the peanuts stuff
and I think as was I actually i think we
when we first met we both bonded over
the fact we taught ourselves to draw by
copying peanuts cartoons so there was a
there was kind of a given to me at least
that this would be a cartoon like and a
cartoon in them in the most pure sense
and we don't get to see that often in
animated features these days I've there
tends to be a movement towards realism
and naturalism and it was actually
really fun to run fast the other
direction back to the stuff that I came
up with and was inspired by growing up
visually you do things in the movie with
different media's a mixed media there's
a there's 2d animation there's a I call
it collage animation stop-motion and
then there's some puppets and things can
you tell us a little bit about the idea
of using those things and yeah well I
you know again in the books one of the
things to me that make them special and
probably why they've been so beloved and
encouraged so many kids to read as
though there's all these unconventional
tricks and techniques that they've pokey
does and some of them work well in a
literary form and don't really translate
to cinema
he has comic books within the book she
has flip aramas which are a staple of
every book where you know an action
scene is about to break out and then
he'll
we go to a very rudimentary flipbook way
of handling it so that was something
from day one when I came on the movie I
thought all right well that's that's
what's going to make this movie unique
or trying to find all these cinematic
techniques that we can do to keep this
unpredictable and keep this in the mind
of these two very imaginative best
friends so the first sequence that that
we boarded when I came on the movie was
this what ended up becoming the sock
puppet sequence in the movie it was
written as this kind of nightmarish
vision of the future of them after
they've been separated and put in
different classes and how their
friendships never going to survive and
it's going to dissolve over time and and
and it wasn't it wasn't anything other
than CG in the script and and I thought
I well let's think about where we are in
the space and you know these boys are in
their treehouse it's probably the
weather's probably terrible outside and
maybe they've taken their socks off
because they're wet and maybe Harald
holds one up and you know and then
suddenly we're in a sock puppet sequence
and the board artist Todd Chris all I
remember is looking at me and it big
excited smile on his face and he's like
can we do that yeah I said we can do it
until somebody tells us no then let's
try it out so so we did it and you know
I've had this experience a few times
where you think you're out on on a limb
and the studio is never going to go for
it and of course after our first
screening it was it was probably the
thing everybody loved the most and not
really opened the door for all these
other things like the collage beats and
we knew we were going to have these kind
of hand-drawn comics to make it make
them feel like they were created by
George and Harold and those be in 2d and
it just you know really felt like the
more of those we could have embedded in
the story all the way through so didn't
just feel like it was a one-off you're
there but like really a stylistic choice
and a creative choice that made it feel
like we were in George and Harold's
point of view you also
designed the environment yeah so as a
production designer you know sort of
responsible for overseeing the look of
all of that stuff characters and
environments and you know everybody that
we brought onto the film you know
character design with rune visited with
Chrissie Bach and Perry maple and
Florian and the rest of the team that we
had everybody kind of we pretty much
gave them the books first
and we're like study you know get the
style start looking at the style and
then just let go like just just draw as
free and as silly as pinkie does and
let's get that up on the screen and and
we found that when we were doing that
like like our design choices weren't oh
we need a specific television set from
1985 for this or whatever it was like
draw a silly TV what does the TV look
like that's silly or you know what the
kids version of what a computer looks
like not not an actual computer yeah and
so those types of things you know that's
sort of the way to Tilke drawers in the
books so we wanted to make sure we took
that inspiration and David was just you
know so supportive of all of those
choices that we wanted to make and
encouraged us and so we felt like well
we can really just kind of sit back and
have fun and be silly with our designs
in these right the voices of course we
have to mention that was there a lot of
improv on the set tell us about working
with with the actor see we just lucked
out I mean where this was a murderer's
row of comedy great and the interesting
thing was because we had those guys in
from so early and they're all such great
comedians but they're also terrific
writers I realized quickly in the in the
first couple sessions I had with them
that I would be a fool not to take
advantage of those skills they had and I
was in the booth with them I like to be
in the booth with the actors and will
read with them and try to just paint a
picture of what the scene needs to do
and then really let them go to town but
they they really brought an
unprecedented amount of improvisations
and adlets and and helped not just find
the voices of their characters but
really develop their characters we
brought them in to early screenings when
the movie really wasn't fully working
yet
those kind of screenings you usually
want to keep an actor away from you want
them to like leave the project but they
they came in and we really kind of
embraced them as creative partners on
the movie and they gave great notes they
great great suggestions every recording
they would you know ask like what's
changed what are we doing how you know
and I would talk them through all that
so they they were so invested in this
and in their characters and hopefully
that that comes through